this is the best interview I've ever had
in my life I love your line of
questioning and um getting to what what
is real I hooked into Tim has a
childlike quality to him and I stay with
that innocence and that and don't take
that innocence's weakness or uh and uh
when I read the scripture
I I feel truth good evil and I find the
good
and
let that just Pierce The Darkness
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening
today I have the pleasure of speaking to
two people
someone you most likely know for his
portrayal of Jesus of Nazareth in
Passion of the Christ Jim Caviezel and
also someone you should know if you
don't already The Man Behind operation
Underground Railroad
Tim Ballard we discussed the new film
The Sound of freedom wherein Mr cavizo
plays Tim Bellard in the telling of his
real life story detailing his fight
against the increasingly worldwide and
pervasive childhood sex trade
the film The Sound of Freedom releases
on July 4th
so about a week and a half ago I got a
text message from Tony Robbins uh
suggesting that I watch a new film
called the sound of freedom and I did
that about four days ago with my wife
Tammy and was quite struck by the movie
and I decided to follow up on it it
details out the efforts of one man Tim
Bellard to investigate uh the a child
sexual slave ring and to rescue the
children that were associated with that
but it also points to a broader social
problem which is the spread of
sexual and slave trafficking worldwide
abetted by the gnat which is a great
Avenue for Psychopathic criminals to
pursue their
darkest desires with very little
risk of being caught especially on the
multinational basis so I've decided to I
to to reach out to Tim Bellard who is
the
um the man who who the movie is about
and to Jim Caviezel who's the actor that
plays him to talk about what all this
signifies and so Tim let's start with
you I mean the movie
makes the case that there is a widely
expanding network of slavery essentially
making itself manifest worldwide
concentrating in no small part on very
young children who are being sold
repeatedly to pedophilic
Psychopaths to have at their will
and of course can be sold repeatedly for
that purpose and the movie makes the
case that this is now an operation
that's rivaling the drug trade in
magnitude so you know it sounds like
yet another right-wing conspiracy so
please why don't you walk us through
what you know and and and help me
understand and everybody watching and
listening exactly what you think is
going on
yeah thank you so much uh Jordan we're
so grateful uh you take your time to do
this with us so I spent 12 years as a
special agent undercover operator with
the Department of Homeland Security most
of my time 90 of that time was spent
investigating these cases child crimes
child trafficking and in fact those
numbers are correct uh that are being
this these are Department of Labor U.N
these are sources that um you know the
the best we have that say that there's
close to Six Million children or more
who are forced into sex slavery labor
slavery or organ harvesting and I can
attest that I have been involved in in
cases involving all three of those forms
of slavery multiple times and is
absolutely is a real thing
um it's not even far far from home uh
it's the United States is the number one
consumer year after year of child rate
material and oftentimes we we're close
to number one in production
um and it's a serious matter you know
the case
um the story and the sound of Freedom
kicks off with the rescue of a little
boy at the Port of Entry uh the southern
border that's a real story a real boy
um that I I was on that Port of Entry I
was 10 years on the southern border so
when you have 85 000 unaccompanied
minors showing up in the last two years
being let into the country without the
sponsor being vetted DNA checked
background checked um you know I called
the economy of pedophilia at the United
States where the demand 85 000 children
thousands of them are under five years
old are are LED into the country so we
have we have a serious serious problem
and uh it's it's not being addressed as
it should be hopefully this film can do
that have have what has been your
experience with regard to so-called
mainstream Media or Legacy media
coverage how much attention has been
paid to this and if not much why and if
reasonably who and how
well I think not not very much has been
uh you know attention has been given by
mainstream media oftentimes it's more
innocent than cynical perhaps where it's
just this is too dark I don't want to
expose our audience to this horrific
thing
um you know we I I film we film our
operations I mean I I'm going to post
today another operation in in West
Africa of a baby Factory I mean these
are real cases where they've they've
kidnapped women
um as young as 13 year olds and children
and they impregnate them they rape them
and they make babies and they take these
babies and sell them for their organs
sell them for sex sell them for a
Satanic ritual abuse like it's it's it
does sound crazy that's why I film it
our operations we film our operations so
that we can show the world this is very
real it's really happening
um and I think if there's two million
children forced into commercial sex
which is this the most uh kind of
credible statistic that we can find a
lot of people are involved so there is a
more cynical answer to your question
which may be there's people that don't
want this exposed the because they're
involved in it so I'm going to harass
you a bit here um from the Wikipedia
page
um there is some not that I'm particular
particular fan of Wikipedia Pages uh
depending on the circumstances but there
are some criticisms of what you're doing
and I thought we might as well
um address them right off the bat bat
because people who are watching are
going to be look man if I was coming
across this for the first time and in
some ways I am
I've got two choices in front of me
don't I I can either presume that you've
discovered something that's ongoing and
of tremendous significance that's
terribly dark or I can assume that the
difficult work that you had done for a
decade
um genuinely addressing these problems
has made you hypersensitive to a threat
and willing to magnify it and it would
be easier just to ignore you as a
consequence now that would be the
preferable
um outcome to such an investigation
wouldn't it so you can as as you said
you can understand why people might want
to avert their eyes from such a thing so
I'm going to walk through these
criticisms and maybe you could you know
you can respond to them and we can get
that out of the way before we go deeper
into the film and and your your uh in
your your uh your operations
so so your group and this is Operation
Underground Railroad and tell me if I
get anything wrong here says it devours
conspiracy theories though founder Tom
Bellard was criticized for refusing to
condemn the Q Anon conspiracy theory
um I have no idea what the hell that
means do you know what that's referring
to
yeah absolutely we um that's that's a
lie in Wikipedia we have absolutely an
rfaqs for years have have condemned the
majority of of what we see
um with conspiracy theories uh so I they
like to attribute me to the Q Anon
movement
um there may be some truths in there but
there's so many falsehoods on top of
that so our FAQs refute that immediately
um because it can it discredits the
movement in fact I would go so far as to
consider that maybe certain people who
don't want this known are responsible
for some of the conspiracy theories in
order to discredit the movement
um and uh they go too far they go too
far in in their assessment of things but
yeah we absolutely have just disavowed
uh what's generally coming out of of Q
Anon yeah well it says you know it's
very vague on Wikipedia it says to
condemn the Q Anon conspiracy theory
well I know perfectly well that there
are more than one conspiracy theories
let's say on Q and on so I'm not even
exactly sure what it's referring to what
is there a particular conspiracy theory
that um you were criticized for refusing
to condemn do you have any more specific
details about that
I mean I I'm not sure what exactly
they're talking about Pro they might be
uh referring to the fact that there's
something called adrenal Chrome where
they take they're taking children's
blood and devouring it and so forth uh
and I've explained my experience with
that and and I just did in West Africa
and other places we've seen this in in
several parts of the continent of Africa
and it's very real it's very real This
Witch doctory they take these children
we they they take their organs they take
their blood they they they drink it they
take the genitalia of children and and
hang it over the rooftop of their
businesses thinking that the the dark
Gods will bless them these are real
things
um and so I might say something like
that and then they connect it to
something uh that a q Anon person says
about you know a celebrity who must be
doing this too but there's no evidence
to back that and they make they make a
false connection there
um and and so that's that's the only
example I can think of okay got it well
the next thing it says is that the the
operation underground Railway fall
mostly claimed that it had entered a
partnership with American Airlines that
was in 2022 so what do you what do you
what do you have to say about that oh
there's a great one so a PR firm uh who
represented
um us made a deal with American Airlines
uh came to us and said shoot the video
they're going to put this video on your
uh we're gonna put there for this video
on the airlines they shot the video of
me I just get a call from our PR Company
to put me in a studio I give a video
that I think I'm talking to the
passengers for one month uh on American
Airlines apparently the deal fell
through the PR Company didn't tell us
that and our our marketing company our
marketing team put out hey we're going
to be on American Airlines the PR
Company apologized we had we fired them
they said we can't believe we didn't get
the message to you and that was it and
of course there's people that want so
badly for us to be wrong or us to not do
what we say we do so they exploited that
I think that was a vice magazine very
incredibly dishonest uh Journal uh I
can't call him journalist us the vice
magazine did they've done a series of
hit pieces on this and I I encourage
people I encourage people to read it
readvice readvice because everything
they say is so ridiculous and so
dishonest right right yes well and I I
do believe if I remember correctly the
advice is also declared bankruptcy in
the last few weeks and I can't imagine
an organization more richly deserving
there was a 2021 follow-up article from
Vice but I don't think we're going to
I'll just read part of it because it's
so ridiculous conflating consensual sex
work with sex trafficking yeah well
that's exactly the kind of Weasley
um what would you call it criticism that
I'd expect from people who were trying
to justify the sorts of behaviors that
you are attempting to expose
um then there's a 2021 article in slate
criticizing a 2014 raid conducted by
operation underground Railway in the
Dominican Republic saying that it was
likely to have traumatized the traffic
children
um Ann Gallagher an authority on human
trafficking wrote in 2015 that our had
an alarming lack of understanding about
how sophisticated criminal trafficking
networks must be approached and
dismantled and called the work of our
arrogant unethical and illegal so and
have a way of that oh thank you I'm
grateful for this opportunity so someone
like Ann Gallagher who lives 3000 miles
away from any operation we've ever done
is not qualified to talk about what our
operations she can't give any uh details
she can't give any examples
um the Slate article is a fun one to
address I've addressed it several times
um we um early on we brought a blogger
down to do to to watch our operations we
we invite people down but if Tony
Robbins has been down
um we invite politicians the Attorney
General of Utah's coming our operations
um if we're hiding something that's the
last thing we would of course do so we
bring this journalist this blogger I
won't call her a journalist
um and we thought she was a friend and
she came and watched a legit legitimate
operation happened in in Dominican
Republic there were seven traffickers
who showed up seven traffickers arrested
there were um 20 plus uh people rescued
nine of them were children you can't you
can't sometimes you can't always uh
control who shows up to the sting party
the traffickers bring who they will but
nine children uh showed up they were all
liberated from the the the the the
um you know the control of their captors
um this blogger then wrote two glowing
stories about it that she witnessed this
she had very minimal exposure to the
operation itself she she witnessed it
some seven years later
she decides to use it in my opinion to
somehow increase her social media
following as our foundation grew and she
writes a story it's in slate now here's
here's the key thing
um
nine children rescued and nine children
had three years of Aftercare services in
this operation provided by International
Justice mission one of the top
authorities in Aftercare and and
fighting human trafficking
um seven traffickers were not only
arrested but all seven were convicted so
she chose the wrong case to criticize
now tellingly
if if anyone's gonna write a story about
that operation good bad or otherwise and
they leave out the part that says seven
traffickers were arrested and seven
traffickers were convicted and nine
children were liberated and had three
years of Aftercare to heal them if you
leave that part out either you are
extremely incompetent as a researcher
and writer or you're a liar either way
the story has zero credibility
on that fact alone that you because she
doesn't even report on those two on
those two essential elements all right
well we've hypothetically dispensed with
Vice which of course is a
yeah well it's pretty funny that that's
what they named their organization as
far as I'm concerned and we'll leave the
Slate issue aside Jim let me ask you a
couple of questions if you don't mind do
you want to first of all tell people
um about your involvement with Angel
Studios a little bit about your career
and why this particular movie sound of
Freedom it's it it's opening what in
early July is it July when does it come
out
it comes out uh July 4th week so next
week next week it's it's it's out in
theaters uh Nationwide so so let me turn
to Jim Jim can you hear me yes yes
all right so yeah do you want to detail
out your your association with Angel
Studios tell everybody first who Angel
studios are what they've done and I've
watched a lot of the chosen by the way
which I thought was extremely high
quality
um do you tell us about the studio tell
us about your involvement with them
about your career and then about your
attraction to this particular movie
well let's start with the movie first
um
I have three uh adopted children from
China
I became aware of the dangers that go on
um with children around the world and
through that process
um
then I became aware of Tim Ballard and
coincidentally then my friend Eduardo
verastigi
brought me this script because
many of the actors that they had offered
it to didn't want to get involved in
this particular project
I read the script I love the movie Taken
and I thought this is like taken but
with a much bigger heart
then Tim Ballard came to the meeting he
had seen two films that I did one was
called The Count of Monte Cristo
and then the other one was The Passion
of the Christ and he felt that I'd be
the right guy to play him Angel Studios
I had nothing no connection to them
until a few months ago when they wanted
to do this movie and they wanted their
idea was to
sell 2 million tickets for these two
million trafficked children
so why why is it that
a number of actors why in your
estimation did a number of actors turn
down the opportunity to play the role
what and and and why and why did you
decide to forego that risk and to and to
climb aboard
I foregoed the risk because when you
have
uh three children that you loved when
you'd give your life for it kind of
connects into Tim Ballard and Tim did
this
for this little girl and the children
that he saves it's something uh is a
greater purpose that even your career uh
you know like I I went through this with
Mel Gibson when we did the passion that
my career was the last thing I thought
of what I thought about was the God I
love and I put this in how I look at it
is is that this God that I love it he
loves me and he deserved to be loved
back and so I I would be nothing without
him he gave me my purpose and this life
so
um
the the
Tim Ballard I was very fortunate that he
had seen those um films and um when I
looked at and I think Tim made this
comparison
Schindler's List was a very
uh powerful weapon but it came 50 years
too late this film is now this is
exposing it now during that time and I
believe that is probably why it's easier
to get an OCTA to do a movie 50 years
later there's no controversy it's over
but the the individuals imagine if
Rwanda if that story had been made that
movie had been made during that time or
that they could see it you know it you
you have to look at these situations and
understand that
um
good people sit back and do nothing and
allow this evil to occur there's got to
be people that stand up in the time that
it occurs and that's what drew me to the
whole story in the first place
and do you do you how how do you feel
about the movie now you've seen the
movie in its entirety it's about to be
released uh it's a fully fledged high
quality production I was particularly
impressed by the cinematography
um it it's also extraordinarily well
edited the acting
um I don't want to flatter you but the
acting is extremely high quality it's
very realistic movie
um how how do you how how do you feel
about your involvement now that
everything is done and and how do you
feel about the what would you say the
production capacity of Angel Studios
which is a relatively you know it's a
relatively new a relative newcomer on
the on the mass entertainment block
when I was sitting next in Tim Ballard
and he leaned over and he started to
weep uh heavily I knew I did my job
so do you want to run us briefly through
I don't want to give away the entire
plot because that would obviously be
pointless but do you want to just run
this briefly through Jim the the the the
plot of the movie and then I'll turn to
Tim and fill in some of the background
details of his life and
so I play Tim Ballard he's a Homeland
Security he sets up these um
uh sting operations to take down these
very very bad men uh to save traffic
children and one particular case
one of the traffickers that he takes
down earned slipachinski uh who's
he he rescues this boy and the little
boy turns to him and says will you
save my sister
and Tim goes back gets the direction
from above and from his wife
and goes back and he sells everything to
find this little girl
so what I liked about the script
so I've noticed that one of the most
effective ways of communicating complex
ideas effectively
is to particularize the problem and so
what happens in this movie is that the
broad problem of sexual of of slavery
and human trafficking and the somewhat
narrower problem of sexual trafficking
of children is zeroed
uh is is what focused on a particular
case and so that gives the movie a very
powerful narrative underpinning right
because
when our problem is particularized and
you can see how it affects actual
specific people's lives it becomes much
more realistic and much more palpable
and I thought the movie did a good job
of that uh Tim do you want to walk
everybody listening through let's go
back into the details of your life now
you worked for this you you worked we
worked for the Special Forces per se and
who who are you working for before you
decided to forego your career and to
pursue this the case that we're
describing
so I worked for 12 years as a special
agent and undercover undercover operator
for the Department of Homeland Security
the investigative division called
Homeland Security investigations 10 of
those years were spent on the border uh
tracking child traffickers people who
would exploit children with child
exploitation material so I really
learned a lot in 2006 the laws changed
in the United States and for the first
time U.S agents were permitted and
encouraged to go overseas and find
children who Americans were abusing and
we could now hold those Americans
accountable as if they had committed
that crime on U.S soil that's that's
what really changed my life because I
started I speak Spanish fluently and
they sent me overseas South of the
Border that's when my eyes opened up and
I started seeing the children that I
used to only see mostly on the on the
pornography on the child expectation
material cases
um but it was tormenting me uh the US
government unwittingly was because if I
couldn't find that connection back to
the United States States the American
kid or the American pedophile I had to
come home but the problem is I've
already been exposed to the children
I've already been exposed to the problem
and oftentimes have made myself debate
and in 2012 I had enough on this case I
kind of went more I went further than
otherwise I probably should have the
movie didn't have time to tell you that
there was another case in Haiti at the
same time that I was working uh thinking
there was a U.S Nexus and I was told in
both instances to come home and you
couldn't work these cases and that's
when I had a very consequential
conversation with my wife and I said if
I stay here if I do this operation with
or without my badge it doesn't matter at
this point I I'm I can do the work we
will save kids
um and um but I I have to lose my job
and we have six children and this is
this is a moral dilemma like I've never
faced in my life and I was hoping my
wife would have responded
with
get your ass home you can't you can't
abandon us you know first of all you're
gonna die without the top cover of the
US government if you continue this and
who's going to pay the bills and feed
the feed the kids
she didn't say that she said to me you
have to quit your job it was that easy
for her
um it became spiritual for her even she
felt a calling and a responsibility that
she might have to reckon with one day
when she meets her maker and I knew that
she felt that way when she told me this
in the crucial moment of decision
about two days before I ended up turning
my badge and gun over and and went
private
she said to me I will not let you
jeopardize my salvation
by not doing this
and when she said those words and I knew
she meant those words that changed
everything for me and we jumped into
really just
an irrational Act of service I might
call it because it wasn't rational in
many in many ways but ultimately it
ended in the operation UC depicted in
the film which shows 54 children uh some
uh some adult young young adult women
were in that group as well rescued on
that island but what the movie doesn't
uh have the time to report is that in
actuality was 120
um there was two other locations being
taken down at the same time and there's
a documentary that's going to follow uh
in in the wake of sound of Freedom
called triple take Angel Studios will
put it out uh documenting the entire
story and so in the end it was
successful and we were able to build
upon that success and I founded
operation Underground Railroad I run
another Foundation that was founded by
Glenn Beck called the Nazarene fund and
we're doing these kind of operations all
over the world today
so how let's go back in time to before
you worked as a security agent for the
homelands homeless or an agent for the
homeland security investigations unit
how did you how were you trained to do
that like what was your background
before you became employed as an agent
and what was it about you that made you
capable of engaging in this sort of
operation
so I I I got a graduate degree in um
International politics and I always
wanted to be in federal law enforcement
my first job was CIA I was there doing
um working in the operations center in
the wake of 9 11. I found out that I
studied terrorism and weapons of mass
destruction uh that was the the actually
the degree I got at the Monterey
Institute of international studies
um and so
um it was an easy recruit into the CIA
because you know 911 had just happened
when I found out that one of the
terrorists Muhammad attah had staged his
attack from Mexicali Mexico across the
border and I speak Spanish I wanted to
go fight terrorism on the southern
border so I ended up jumping on the ship
from CIA and I joined the newly created
Homeland Security Department and it
became a special agent for six months I
was tracking those kind of movements uh
you know not not human trafficking or
child exploitation but money guns
terrorism six months into that Endeavor
I was called into the office of a
supervisor and they asked me if I would
please forgo everything that I wanted to
do with my career and help them start a
child crimes unit I do not know why they
asked me uh one thing he did say to me
was you're a young agent but you're a
person of faith and we know that about
you and that's that's a requirement or
you're you're your soul will be crushed
the Bible is a root of wisdom
inspiration and spiritual nourishment
the Halo app empowers you to explore the
Bible's profound teachings and to
effortlessly incorporate them into your
daily life a great place to start while
you deepen your understanding of the
Bible is to check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year available on
the hollow app exclusively for brief
daily readings and Reflections here you
can dive into an extensive library of
Bible reading plans accompanied by
insightful Reflections and audio guided
meditations whether you're a seasoned
Bible reader or just starting your
journey hallow provides a platform for
you to engage with scripture like never
before studying the Bible's literary
Brilliance has influenced countless
writers poets and artists throughout
history by studying the Bible yourself
you'll gain a deeper appreciation for
the power of Storytelling symbolism and
metaphor enriching your understanding of
literature across different genres the
Hallow app also helps you connect with a
community of like-minded individuals
sharing experiences insights and
encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hallow.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along
the way enrich your education and
nurture your mind and soul today
download the Hallow app at hallow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan for an
exclusive free month free trial of all
six thousand plus prayers and
meditations
I would like you if you would to tell us
to the degree that you can
what you were typically dealing with
when you started when you started
working for the child sex crimes unit
let us know what you saw
let us know what you what that did to
you because that sort of thing that
changes people's conceptions of humanity
per se let's say the nature of the
cosmos and what it means to be human
right I mean when you're when you're in
contact with people who are capable of
that level of Darkness you start to
understand something about the nature of
the human soul that you can't understand
any other way and that can be a I mean
that's the sort of thing that gives
people post traumatic stress disorder
when they're soldiers so and and now you
said also your supervisors had an
inkling that you might be protected
against that at least to some degree
because of your faith so let's walk
through what you learned and encountered
first what what did you see when you
were working as part of this child sex
crimes unit
what I saw was so shocking Jordan uh I
thought child sex crimes would be 15
year olds 16 year olds uh my brain
couldn't comprehend something more evil
than abusing that age the very first
case I worked in 2002 I believe I was
given a bunch of VHS videos some hard
drives to look at that had been seized
in a warrant the very first image I saw
um were um
there were three uh three little boys
ah
that were probably seven five and three
and they looked uh like they looked like
my children they had you know they had
blonde blonde eye blonde hair blue eyes
and they were being just raped raped
these three little boys by this
pedophile
and I was so shocked I fell to my knees
I dry heaved
thinking I was going to throw up into
the waste basket I jumped into my car I
drove to my children's School my three
oldest kids I checked them out I still
remember in my mind I can still see
dentist dentist appointment I wrote and
I grabbed them I took them home and just
sobbed on the floor my wife came in and
I just I wouldn't let the kids go just
holding them shaking
um
that was my very first experience uh you
talked about PTSD I absolutely deal with
PTSD to this day
um I I took too long to actually deal
with it uh that's another story
um
and I thought I can't I can't do this I
can't do this
um I started getting help immediately uh
because I didn't want to quit and uh
that that's that's what this is
that's what this is and those kind of
videos have increased over the last
couple years by five thousand percent
yeah well in in Canada
um we just had a report from an
organization called the Western Standard
that one million child sexual
exploitation photos and videos have been
identified in an Alberta child porn
investigation one million photos eight
arrests made okay so that's some
indication of the widespread nature of
the problem now you said that when you
first encountered this material it made
you physically ill and also terrified
for the safety of your children but then
also it necessitated you seeking
um health I suppose or Aid I mean I've
worked with people who've had
post-traumatic stress disorder generally
what happens is that tragedy is not
enough to give someone post-traumatic
stress disorder even if it's rather
severe it has to be a combination of
tragedy and malevolence and the real
trauma comes as a consequence of contact
with evil with malevolence and what
people generally have to do in order to
recover from that is to develop a rather
profound philosophy of evil and you know
a religious faith in in its most
fundamental Essence is a philosophy of
Good and Evil it it does detail out the
Heart of Darkness among human beings
point out to people this is particularly
although you not not uniquely true of
the Christian tradition but particularly
true that that capacity for evil lurks
in the heart of everyone and that are
fundamental moral obligation as we
Soldier and here on Earth is to overcome
that proclivity within and also to stand
up against it in the external world and
so you said you received some Aid after
you had been exposed to this first set
of videos
um what what is it about the way you
looked at the world that had to change
in order for you to adapt to what you
were encountering
well I had to come to grips with the the
an idea that I had never been confronted
with before that there are people and
not a few but millions of people only
millions of of pedophiles could justify
a demand of millions of child
exploitation uh material videos and so
forth uh the first person you see
arrested in the movie is a real person
named ursulchinski in sound of Freedom
he had over 2 million pieces of child
rape material in his house so um to to
be confronted with the reality that
there are people on this planet and like
like I said not a few but but Millions
who want to indulge in watching
five-year-old children be raped and
sexually assaulted in ways that and I'm
sorry to be so raw but I feel
comfortable with you Dr Peterson but uh
to to to watch children's bodies
actually break
in the act of sexual assault acts that
your mind couldn't conjure up if you
tried to conjure it up and that it's
real that is so shocking to the system
um it changes your life forever I I tell
people if I feel like I've had a million
holes burned into my brain because I've
watched thousands of hours of that kind
of material not only not only watch it
and I love the scene that Jim depicts
where he's it's that's very real I I
break I can't watch I can't watch the
movie but the movie's very good the
movie doesn't show any of this by the
way it doesn't show anything like this I
don't want people to run away and be
scared but you see the scene where the
the camera flashes
um a close-up into Jim's eyes and that's
that was me for for 10 years
not only watching but writing writing it
in details for the court to see for the
prosecutors to see and and raising
children at the same time that are the
very same age and fortunately or
unfortunately for me I have now I have
nine children that at the time I I left
the government at six and so I can
always identify the age of a child with
one of my own children and my mind was
almost automatically doing is I would
superimpose my own children's faces and
persons onto these children and that's
that led to
um that led to the PTSD I'll be honest
um and almost a paranoia about what
would happen to my children and watching
my children and I've come a long ways
and and I'm I'm able to deal with it but
I I I I was determined never to quit and
so I just sought more help and I I won't
quit so
okay so Tim I'm I'm gonna walk you
through what I know about how people
turn into the sort of pedophile that
you find so you and everyone else I
suppose or virtually everyone else finds
so mysterious
so
I'm going to refer first to the story of
Cain and Abel because it actually puts
its finger on the process in a stunning
manner
so what happens in that story is that
two different Pathways to adaptation are
detailed out and they become the
Cardinal Pathways of adaptation that
characterize the whole human race
immersed as it is from that point onward
in history instead of in the Garden of
Eden and one is the pathway of Cain and
the other is the pathway of Abel now
Abel makes high quality sacrifices he's
all in right he puts himself on the line
and he does the real thing and as a
consequence God finds God uh finds he
finds favor with God and His sacrifices
are rewarded he does well and everyone
loves him and he thrives and Cain
his sacrifices are not of the same
quality he tries to cut the corners and
to and to pull the wool over his eyes
and and God's eyes and everyone else's
eyes and as a consequence his sacrifices
are rejected
and instead of clueing the hell in and
waking up and taking responsibility for
his failure he decides that he's going
to call out God for creating a cosmos
that's cosmically unfair and unjust and
the evidence for that is Kane's failure
and Abel's success and so he has a
little chat with God and he basically
calls him out and says you know I'm
breaking myself in half here and
nothing's going my way and Abel gets
everything he wants and you know how
dare you make a cosmos so radically
unjust and improper and why don't you
just straighten yourself out and God
says if you did well you would be
rewarded for it and you should look to
yourself and then he says something even
worse and this is very subtle because
um it's complicated to understand it
unless you look at multiple translations
or potentially the original Hebrew which
I can't read but I read the multiple
translations God says to Cain
the spirit of sin crouches at your
doorstep like a sexually aroused
predatory animal
and you have invited it in
to have its way with you
and so now if you study
the development of the fantasies of very
very dark people
you see that they brewed and fantasize
in isolation for years and the fantasies
get darker and darker and darker so
they're bitter and resentful to begin
with
and then they start fantasizing about
well what they would want that can take
a sexual end or it can take a very
violent and or it can take both and what
they're really after is the ultimate in
Revenge and on the sexual front they
find a kick in extending the what would
you call it unacceptability of the
fantasy one stage at a time
um
the the famous and extremely attractive
sexual serial killer what was his name
he's a famous photograph of him like
this very attractive man do you remember
his dad Bundy Ted Bundy Ted Bundy
detailed out exactly how his fantasies
progressed as he became more and more
involved with pornography and what
happens in some sense is that these
people who are nursing these terrible
fantasies want to stay on the edge of
novelty and so their fantasies get
darker and darker and darker as they
progress down that road and so after a
thousand such micro progressions they
end up in exactly the sort of pit that
you're describing and some of that is
pure sexual kick because of the novelty
and but it's got this sadistic and
perverse uh vengeful twist and you could
think about it this way you know I think
it says in the gospels that you know it
would be better that that a most
Millstone was hung around your neck and
that you were cast into the abyss than
to do harm to any of God God's children
let's say and the that's actually where
the perverse Delight comes because the
most egregious possible sin let's say is
the violent sexual abuse of the most
innocent possible person and the
perverse novelty kick is highest at
exactly that point and then that just
goes from bad to worse and there's a
thousand or even ten thousand micro
decisions that go along with that
there's also a great book called
Ordinary men this is well worth reading
although it's a bloody catastrophe to
read I'll tell you it details out how a
group of German policemen who were moved
to Poland during World War II were
transformed from ordinary middle class
working class or sorry ordinary working
class men
um old enough to not have been raised
under the Nazi regime by the way and so
not propagandized into a kind of
mindless obedience how they went from
being perfectly ordinary policemen
to the sort of people who could take
naked pregnant women out into the middle
of the field and shoot them in the back
of the head and it isn't like they had
an easy time with that some of them
reported the same sort of thing that you
reported when you first watched that
video they would they what they were
being called upon to do stage by stage
made them physically ill and they had a
commander who actually had told them
that they could leave the service if
they didn't want to continue with their
duties but they felt Duty bound not to
lead leave their comrades having to mop
up the terrible situation but it does a
lovely job of detailing out how your
movement from normality to Absolute
perversity is a consequence of ten
thousand micro
um what would you say micro violations
of your own conscience not all of the
micro obviously so you know you need to
know about the vengefulness you need to
know about the kick of sadism that's
that novelty kick that produces a
dopaminergic kick that heightens sexual
satisfaction and so there's an there's
an element of sadistic misery that can
add novelty to sex that's particularly
attractive to people who are bitter and
resentful because they actually can't
find any willing sexual partners and so
they're angry at the world and shake
their fist to God because of it and so
anyways that's a bit of the
developmental course of such of such a
lovely descent into hell and and the
interesting thing about it is that
people Brew Day like you don't get to
the point where you're watching
pornographic videos of children being
raped without hundreds or even thousands
of hours of increasingly demented
voluntary fantasy and that's that
allowing the spirit of sin that would
otherwise crouch on your doorstep to
enter your house and have its way with
you right it's like a collaborative
Venture with Satan himself that's the
most straightforward way of describing
it and so well so that's I don't know
what you have to say about that but I'll
let you have at her I'll say this that
everything you're saying absolutely he
resonates with my anecdotal experiences
dealing with these people I look into
their eyes and what you're describing is
what I see though I've never been able
to articulate it like you just have so I
appreciate being armed with with um with
an understanding that it will help me uh
evangelize more clearly to others about
the dangers of of
over stimulation and overview support of
pornography and and shaking hands with
the devil so thank you for that that was
very insightful
so I I spent a bit of time
um not a lot but a bit of time inside a
maxim security prison when I was a kid I
worked with a very strange psychologist
that was there and one of the things
that really shocked me and I I think
this shocked me enough to change my
whole life was
I I met these I met this one prisoner
who was a pretty non-descript looking
character he took me for a walk out in
the yard away from a gym full of like
weight lifting Ax Murderer monsters and
rapists and we went for a walk out in
the yard and the psychologist called us
back and told me later in the office
that this guy who's about five two
pretty non-pre-possessing guy had uh
made two policemen
Neil in front of him begged for their
lives in reference to their families and
then shot them both in the back of the
head and and kicked them aside and the
shocking thing to me was you know you
kind of think that
if you met pure evil it would it would
have a monstrous form and you know the
thing that shocked me about that was the
non-descript nature of this guy you know
his his absolutely banal ordinariness
the fact that you could just walk past
him on the street you'd never know he
wasn't some monster you know the
Monstrous character of Satan in your
imagination is you know a figure that's
terrifying to behold instead of someone
normal you know what I mean normally in
that cringing sense these people that
you've interacted with like what's your
what's your reaction to them when you
talk to them the pedophiles when you
talk to them and when you arrest them
my experience is very similar to what
you just described very nondescript
people of all walks of life we've we've
we've arrested and I've interrogated
um Educators uh lawyers law enforcement
clergyman
um and and uh sitting across from them
there's but with no apparent physicality
that would tell you who they are but I
will say this when they start talking
and I look into their eyes
that's when I can I sense something that
that really scares the hell out of me
um and the way they talk about
children when they get there and it's
it's something that they've been able to
normalize and they're speaking to me
about children almost like they're
talking about you know the weather or
you know talking about buying and
selling children like you talk about
buying and selling computer parts or an
automobile or something and that's where
I thought you something has taken over
you something non-human has made you
less human
um and I've never been able to figure it
out uh only that it creeps me out and
and
um and I usually end up getting them to
confess because they have brought
themselves to a place where they think
they're okay they think that it's
somehow normal
I don't know if that makes sense how do
they do Dr Peterson well well the the
degree of rationalization that has to
with each with each step forward in the
progress of the fantasy there has to be
a step forward in the self-deception
with regards to self-description right
so imagine that you're you're attempting
to cling to a sense of yourself at least
as normal but even maybe as a moral
agent I mean the the more forthright
pedophiles claim that they're only
allowing children to express their true
sexual desires and that what they're
actually doing is forming the best
relationship with the children that
they've ever had now of course there's
part of them that knows that that's an
absolutely bloody screaming hellish lie
but you get to that lie like I said with
a thousand micro lies right and you're
modifying your self-conception along the
way I mean have you had these people
justify themselves to you and if so by
what means do they attempt to do that
so one person that comes to mind
absolutely the answer is yes and one
person that comes to mind is the person
depicted in the film oshensky uh this
person had written uh articles
self-published of course he had a book
that he actually sold on Amazon and his
understanding or his his justification
was that the puritanical Society of this
country has crushed the true uh and and
and beautiful and righteous uh sexual
experience uh which the most natural
would be between a man and a child a
prepubescent child a prepubescent child
is is is the is the most beautiful form
of humanity and
um and why why take that away from a
child's children would be well uh
conditioned to to to confront the
challenges of life if only they could
experience orgasmic pleasure even in
their prepubescence
um this is how they talk right right and
right yeah well that you saw because of
that there was attempts made in the
1970s by French intellectuals surprise
surprise to have the age of consent
reduce radically and that was always the
rationale it was an extension of the
patriarchal oppression theory in some
sense right that all sexual expression
is essentially pure and good in its most
fundamental form and it's all warped by
social pressure and if we were just
allowed to express ourselves in every
manner that we saw fit that everyone
would be free and we wouldn't suffer any
more from the constraints of of
tyrannical Society right and it's just
convenient for the bloody pedophiles
that that happens to justify them doing
whatever they the hell they want to
children who are obviously too young to
consent
right so he is a good example I forgot
about that in the book Jim let me ask
you so now you didn't have to go through
the same things that Tim did and you
obviously weren't subject to the same
kind of exposure but you had to play
this role and you had to act out in your
imagination the darkness that
characterized the people who played your
enemies let's say on the screen what
were the consequences for you of having
to delve even on the fictional landscape
into this entire uh what would you say
underworld domain
well let's
um start with your story initially when
you brought up Cain and Abel
um in my years of working with agents
like Tim
and I actually worked with other agents
because Tim was very busy doing Missions
at the time and I got to go in to a lot
of his world I mean those are the guys
that I play so I don't imitate other
actors I go and meet these guys and
really learn and study what they do Cain
and Abel for example
able
is doing good things for God how would
Cain hurt God by killing Abel by
wounding him
when I go and play for example a serial
killer or a man that you mentioned
earlier Ted Bundy who my friend uh broke
that case and found out who he was Mike
tando so you're the Beast that comes in
you he he he
um comes in and he um
deceives you and and starts with the ego
and the whole thing and then eventually
the turn is is how that you're
eventually not fair on non-servient uh
becomes
um one who how can I wound God the most
by killing the most innocent child and
it wounds God in the greatest way when
you take these innocent children who've
done nothing and have no sin and these
guys
um uh um have the attitude which you
were mentioning earlier all the cutting
of the corners and whatnot and
ultimately they
um can kill the most innocent and
effectively wounds God's heart the most
um I
spent a great deal time I did this movie
uh Deja Vu and I played it uh Unabomber
and I was on the phone with
um
um a friend a friend of mine who broke
the case and uh on Ted Bundy and I
talked to him a lot about uh serial
killers and then
um I got to look at the
um with the FBI and the ATF gave me uh
through Jerry Bruckheimer and Tony Scott
I got all these videos to look at
and the the
um we I was looking at unabomers uh guys
that um blow things up and um an actual
serial killers but it was written more
like a Ted Bundy
um and not a a man who is writing
Destiny and all of these things that
he'd exchanged his life to take out
um whoever they want to take out and but
the the but the voice was very similar
and so I don't go to Satan to play
in this particular
um Story I played this this guy this um
bomber
and I don't go to the devil to play the
devil I think make many actors make that
mistake go to God to tell you who the
devil is that's what I do and it also
gives me a protection
what's the difference what's the
difference Jim like because that also
Bears on how you protect yourself from
such things
um
the difference and are you saying um the
difference in the the difference is is
that I play the truth so if you go and
play go to the devil to play the devil
the devil will deceive you and put
something up there that uh deceives the
public he'll always try to hide in the
shadow he'll always try because he
doesn't like the light even though he's
called the light the Illuminator
um the Lucifer
um and he tries to mimic God he tries to
be like God so there's always like um
if God has love and what we see is love
he creates lust he's always trying to be
like that it's like uh Kane trying to
rip off Abel cutting the corners and
um so committing to well there's a
tendency even in Milton's uh in in in
Milton's Paradise Lost
there's been two readings of that
forever and one of them is that Milton's
Satan is
um an anti-hero of the most profound
sort really the embodiment of evil and
the other reading is that
um Milton Satan is a a disguised hero
and the Eternal what would you say the
Eternal rebel against established order
and
someone to emulate in consequence and
that Milton somehow knew that and was
coding that not precisely secretly but
subtly and I think that's a huge mistake
I mean I've familiarized myself with
Paradise Lost and I think that Milton
was an extraordinarily subtle writer in
that he got everything as right as
anyone ever has but the reason I'm
bringing that up is because so this is
okay this is a complicated thing to
untangle but
one of the things you see in Hollywood
portrayals of villains you saw this in
the Silence of the Lambs you see it
frequently in Mafia portrayals is that
the villain is inadvertently or even
sometimes purposefully glorified and
it's partly because he's a rule breaker
and and has the attraction that goes
along with that but I also wonder too if
it's it has something to do with what
you were describing is that the writers
and the actors find themselves
when they're trying to portray evil
pulled towards falseness in that
representation as part of the proclivity
of evil to hide itself and the danger in
that is twofold and one is the danger of
deceiving the public as to the true
nature of evil because there's nothing
heroic about it quite the contrary and
the second danger I wonder about you
know there's all this speculation about
Heath Ledger and the consequences that
for him of having played the Joker in
such a dark Manner and you know I don't
know what to make of that although I do
think there is some danger in having to
Journey down a path of emulating evil in
order to represent it now you said that
you turned to God so to speak to protect
yourself against false representations
of evil but also in some ways to Shield
yourself and it sounds to me reminiscent
of what Tim's uh superiors mentioned to
him when they said to him that his faith
might protect him from this question
what was
okay go ahead man
this is the best interview I've ever had
in my life I love your line of
questioning and um getting to what what
is real my job
uh is to give what I know to be
absolutely certain and real I hooked
into Tim has a childlike quality to him
and I stay with that innocence and that
and don't take that innocence's weakness
or uh and uh
so when I read the scripture I I feel
truth
good evil
and I find the good
and let that just pierce the darkness
and it has to pierce and I know what
that light is and I know that deception
that when I start hearing about for
example in your life when you there's
two masters here one is from the evil
Wicked side but he comes in through your
ego and the other one is the light side
that tells you might what you might not
want to hear but you ought to hear and
it's not manipulative it's truth so I I
go to that side then I pray then I go
through it like The Passion of the
Christ I looked at the Shroud of Turin
and there were two men Christian Tinsley
and Keith vanderlin who are experts in
makeup and the first both of these men
were agnostic and they looked at the
Shroud that Mel Gibson presented to them
and one particular way the way it is
uh through the negative however they
were able to show it you can see the
track lines of Jesus you can see the the
the actual
um bamboo sticks that they used to to
initially hit him and then you see the
cat of nine tails the track lines they
look like the Grand Canyon in your skin
and it shocked them now these guys look
at everything from decapitations murders
and everything
prior to this I did a movie a long time
ago in New York
and I was with homicide and I got to see
the contortion of a face when someone
gets murdered and it's hard to watch but
when you start going into this which is
children there is something that I can't
even fathom even with the protection of
almighty God because it took me two
years to get over this two years in the
a friend of mine Debbie came into the
room and at around three o'clock in the
middle of the night she I was in a chair
and she heard me just weeping now I
would go into these black holes and I
have no idea I don't remember it but
this was all of the screaming that I had
to hear I didn't want to hear it but I
had to hear it and then I was able to
transform that into the movie that you
just saw when I took asked Alejandro
monteverdi to move to our DP to take it
and show him my eyeball so you would see
a 20-foot eye to see what Tim goes
through to rip his heart out now it's
not like uh this is what I want to
experience any more than I want to get
on a cross and have uh my heart broken I
went through hypothermia I had to have
open heart surgery I was electrocuted
struck by lightning I understand
the the the
necessity of what I was going to have to
go through could help bring people back
to God to wake them up and
quite frankly more people now Jordan are
more afraid of the devil than they are
of God because they want a happy Jesus
and the problem is is that eventually
Jordan we all are going to die
eventually that that is going to happen
but people the the power of the devil
deceives to say no no you're going to be
around for a long long time and and they
never wake up and eventually there's a
judgment and then you have to decide or
God decides not how you want to see
yourself anymore but how God sees you
and how God sees you is who you really
are and so that's how I I chose to to go
at this particular case I had no choice
but to go in and I hear the screams in
my heart I hear the screams because of
the agents that I got to work with got
to show me things and they one
particular time he says are you sure you
want to go further but I was weeping so
hard I said this is what Tim goes
through this is what I got I got to see
it in order to go into there there to to
take people to a level of will you do
something will you do something at some
point it ends for all of us and so the
pain in my heart
is much better than the pain in the
future and if I have to see that to save
my children
to motivate me to save my niece to tell
my sister no walking home at 13 years
old from school is not a good choice not
a good choice my sister says to me no I
want my sister my daughter excuse me to
have the same kind of experience I have
and I said no
not until this changes you need to
understand so and my sister is a good
great mother but she wasn't aware
because the media that's supposed to do
a good job to tell the truth well
they're going into that direction which
is let's kind of twist it and change it
and not talk about it or the three
letter agencies that aren't telling the
truth go ahead Jordan
how has this changed you how is how is
experiencing that material and having to
play it out changed you I I I'd give my
life
and a heartbeat changed me I'm less
concerned about myself than I am about
hurting I I will tell you this right now
I would absolutely die if this
If This Were to
change
the world and get rid of trafficking and
pornography and all of the
eight arms of this octopus that has to
be destroyed the only way you can
destroy is take the head out if that hit
I'd give my life for it in a heartbeat
Tim let me ask you a question Jim
referred to this is an awkward question
I don't know how to progress with it
exactly right but he said that he tried
to play you with a certain kind of
innocence and you know there's a gospel
line and the line is unless you become
as a little child you will in no way
enter the kingdom of heaven and it's a
very very subtle line because it doesn't
say
unless you stay as a child right it says
unless you become as a child and and
that's a very
it's a very paradoxical injunction and
it means something like this it means
if you ReDiscover the innocence and
humility and capacity for play and
wonder
and open ended trust that you had as a
child
but you still have all the wisdom that
you have as an adult after having seen
the world then you have entered into you
might say a new domain and a more
elevated form of being and Jim said that
he was struck when talking to you about
uh it with regard to this childlike
innocence that he saw on you which is
very peculiar thing to observe in
someone who's had to expose himself to
all the terrible things that you've
encountered and so
I don't I don't have a more fully
developed question than that I I guess I
just like your response to that set of
observations
I do think I think I know what Jim's
talking about
um
when we're doing operations as you see
depicted in sound of Freedom it's some
crazy stuff we're going into crazy
places we're talking to uh monsters and
demons and if I were to apply all the
things I I know the things that take me
down the images of children
um I could be jaded and and less less
innocent
um I think this might go back to the the
the the the the boss who asked me to
start this work back in 2002
by saying that we think you can handle
this because of your faith so when I I
do try to be a child like childlike when
it comes to my relationship with with
God and there's a scripture
that I repeat in my head constantly as I
am going into these dark places and
that's where I become like a child
through that recitation and my
relationship with God or even more
particularly with Jesus
um because it's Jesus who says the line
and you've already quoted it Jordan uh
better than a millstone be placed around
your neck and you toss through the
bottom of the seed and that you should
hurt one of these little ones
um that's so powerful to me because it's
it's so it it allows me to read to read
reduce everything to just an innocent
I hope childlike relationship with With
My Savior with my god
um because I know where he stands on
this and I might not know everything and
I don't know how this is going to
resolve in my head I don't know how I'm
going to heal the millions of of holes
burned into my brain but I do know that
if I subject myself completely to to an
understanding and a testimony that that
Jesus believes something he gets mafioso
this is cement shoes kind of talk uh
it's not it's not it's not flipping
tables outside the temple I mean he's
talking about violence he's speaking
violence but it's it's righteous and
that's where he stands on children being
abused and that's where I find so
there's a there's another idea there's
another idea that lurks in the passion
account hey that that's really quite
stunning and horrible
so the the passion story is an
archetypal tragedy and the reason for
that is that
a tragedy is when something terrible
happens to someone but uh a more
profound tragedy is when the worst
possible thing happens to the least
deserving person
and so that's the passion story in some
ways in a nutshell right you have a man
who by Universal admission even on the
part of his enemies is at minimum a very
good man who undergoes the worst
possible sequence of betrayal and
Punishment and so that's the story of
the tragedy of human life writ large but
there's more to it than that because
there's a mythological insistence along
with that that Christ was not only
crucified but that he had to descend
into the depths of Hell itself and
Harrow it and what that means to me
psychologically speaking let's say is
that you're called upon before rebirth
that's a good way of thinking about it
to not only bear the brunt of the
tragedy of existence but to face
malevolence head on right to go into the
deepest and darkest possible places and
what what do you say it's it's and and
well redeeming them to the degree that
that's possible
simultaneously redeem yourself and so
the notion there is that the brightest
possible light is only possible through
the descent into the darkest possible
realm of of Blackness and that actually
goes beyond death into malevolence
itself now Jim said you know because you
might say well there's nothing that you
should be more afraid of than death but
Jim said you know he's appalled enough
about the existence of malevolence that
he would be willing to give his life to
eradicate it and so that obviously means
that for Jim
malevolence itself is a more terrifying
Specter than than mere death or even
mere suffering and then there is this
gospel notion that unless you're willing
to take the weight of Hell onto yourself
essentially
um voluntarily that you can't go through
that process of descent and rebirth and
that is associated in the in the gospel
accounts let's say with that rebirth
into the spirit of childhood and so
you you have
done what you could to face
the ultimate reaches of Darkness itself
what has that done for you and then also
you made some very interesting comments
about your wife you know you said that
in some ways you were hoping she would
tell you to you know be sensible and
come home but she didn't she told you to
go put yourself on the line and there's
a huge story there that's touched on in
the movie but but not delved into in any
to any great regard
um how has
your encounter with
the darkness that you've seen made you a
better person and and what has that done
with your relationship with your wife
I think it's it's made me a better
person because the the weight that you
speak of that that is on your back is
unbearable unless you can
give it to some other power in this case
in my case to Jesus himself and that's
what to subject myself completely and
repeat his words in my mind because I
know where he stands on it he'll take it
from me and I felt that I have felt that
in ways I can't even articulate that
don't make any sense on a scientific
level I the burden is lifted and that's
what gives me Clarity and courage to do
things I otherwise wouldn't dream of
doing uh in order to help children and
it's it's a concept that my wife
understands in fact I'll tell you this
she it's like she morphed into some kind
of a therapist in that moment after she
told me that her her salvation might be
on the line she's much more advanced
than I am in every way and especially
spiritually and she helped me to see
that uh very thing that give the burden
to to God and and then you can be but
you have to subject yourself like a
child in order to do that and recognize
you can't on your own do it but she she
ran me through this exercise don't know
where she got it maybe it was a download
from heaven but she said do you see the
two paths you're going on either you're
going to Colombia and you do this
operation and what does that look like
and and I said it looks horrifying it's
scary it's dark because there's cobwebs
I I mean I was literally imagining this
there's there's spiders there's evil
things and she said what's the other
path and I said well the other path is
is light
um it's you know I I can see at 50 I get
to retire and then I don't have to you
know I I'm I'm paid a federal government
salary my whole life and benefits and
that seems secure to me and I that seems
comfortable then she says close your
eyes and and you're with your maker
you've passed through this life and
you're talking to your maker and he has
two questions for you one could you have
saved the kids
and two did you do it
that's your interview and she's and and
I got it shocked me I thought oh that's
going to be a bad interview uh if I
don't have the right answer if I don't
make the right decision here and then
she says okay now go back to those two
paths what do you see and I'm telling
you the the cobwebs and creepy things
we're now on the path of staying in my
federal government comfortable job I
thought what might I lose what blessings
might not come and then she said what do
you see down the path of Colombia
and she said I see I said I see warmth I
see I can't see everything but that's
the path I want and I think that's what
that means is I will give it to God and
do the right thing and subject myself
like a child
I hope that made sense well well you
know look
the reason that people lie
and the reason they remain silent
is because they think that things will
be easier for them and better
at least in the short term
but the psychological literature on this
is pretty damn clear I think I think
clearer
than any other element of The Clinical
Psychology literature which is that
you avoid things that stand in your way
that frighten you at your great peril
if you cower from them in silence or you
turn away seeking Security even or even
sensible security
you violate the principle of your own
strength
and if you violate the principle of your
own strength you become weak and if
you're weak there is no security
like if you're weak and you have a
pension you're weak with a pension all
that'll mean is that you'll live longer
in Terror that's not helpful and the
alternative and that there's also a an
ethos in the biblical stories in
particular and it's a very interesting
ethos it's very much worth knowing and
one is that
if you
say the truth and and nothing else
you'll have a immense Adventure as a
consequence you won't know what's going
to happen to you and you have to let go
of your clinging to the
to the outcome you have to let go
but the truth will reveal the world the
way it's intended to be revealed and the
consequence for you will be that you'll
have the adventure of your life
and the other part of that ethos is this
and it makes perfect sense to me I I
can't see how it can be any other way
which is that
whatever makes itself manifest as a
consequence of the truth is the best
possible reality that could be manifest
even if you can't see it and you know in
my own life I've been attacked many
times by people who were attempting to
demolish my reputation and take me out
and that's put my family at risk and
many times we've gone through this a lot
and what we have observed is that if we
stick to our guns and we say what we
believe to be the case and I say we
because it's a collaborative Enterprise
I'm always discussing things with my
family that there's a period of intense
discomfort
and the but the the in the aftermath of
that and that's often several months or
sometimes even several years later
things switch around and reverse in in a
manner that brings benefits that can't
even be fathomed
so so and it is a matter of Faith right
so the faith is something like this look
are you going to make your way through
life with silence and falsehoods are you
going to make your life your way through
life with truth and there's going to be
a price for the truth but your vision
showed you there was a price for the
security too right once once you allowed
your imagination to manifest itself you
saw that the pathway of security was
actually the one that was covered with
spider webs demons and snakes and you
know I see that I saw that with faculty
members at the University over and over
they would take the so-called secure
path forward and all they did was
violate the Integrity of their own Souls
right all that security is false and
obviously your wife for some reason it's
quite the miraculous part of that story
I would say that your wife was behind
you like that especially because you
said you had six kids at the time you
know so how do you think she knew this
you said her faith is more developed
than yours and and that she knows things
you don't but what was it about her life
did you think that enabled her to stand
behind you and this crazy Venture you
went on when she had
every reason to make you mean you were
the movie says you were within what
months of vesting your pension how many
12 weeks something like that
I I don't I don't I can't remember the
exact time but yeah that was the my
accountant came to me and showed me how
much how many millions of dollars this
would amount to that I was walking away
from it was ridiculous I want to say 12
million dollars or something a number I
couldn't even fathom but you're walking
away from that and that really tossed me
and that's the thing that led me to
mccatherine and said this is what we'd
be walking away from why does she have
this thing
um I it's a mystery to me I I can say
this having having given birth and
raised six children I've watched that
process it's there's something I think
that happens to to women at least in the
case of my wife uh that um there's some
insight that comes from that process and
and and childbirth and rearing a child
that she's had to rely on God just to
get through that process and then have
this little creature that you're in
charge of I I think her relationship
with God allowed through motherhood
allowed her to have insights
um that I didn't have I think she came
with certain gifts as well that before
this life uh but whatever it was she saw
immediately and and on the spot was able
to run me through that exercise that
really is consistent with with your
understanding of that process uh Dr
Peterson so
um I don't know she's a miracle she's a
miracle to me and none of this would
have happened without her well okay so
you you quit your job and you put your
pension on the line and your wife was
not only fully on board with that but
perversely enough encouraged you to do
so
how has it how has the financial support
that made your continued existence and
also the operations that you've
undertaken
how has that manifested itself since
like you you don't have your pension and
the government behind you but obviously
you've gathered resources around you
personally and and practically how tell
me how that came about
well I'll add this piece because I that
was my big concern and Catherine said to
me and she believed it this is all in
that same conversation she said I don't
care if we end up living in a tent
we will not go back to our maker instead
we didn't try to help these children so
that's so that helped ease my mind
because I thought well then okay if we
lose our house uh now the the the
blessings did come uh you know uh Glenn
Beck was the person who actually funded
the rescue operation that you see
depicted in the film that very first one
um he got our he got us started put a
huge amount of faith and frankly risk in
in in in doing that
um but that was going to get us only
about six to eight months before we
would be in trouble but what happened
was the success happened the peace that
I felt in making the decision to go was
that New Path that I couldn't see
everything but it felt right it felt
good it felt Godly and I knew it'd be
okay and we've never had a worse month
in the month before we've only grown
with success spread success donations
start coming in Opportunities come in
and frankly I think I'll be better off
financially uh as I look at my future
than I would have been otherwise right
now you we we should just dwell on that
for a minute so we just we just won't
dwell on how unlikely that is say so
let's let's just go through this so you
make this crazy decision to quit your
job and to forgo your your pension even
though you've basically vested it and
you're well into your career you're to
the point where in principle you could
have contemplated retiring and sitting
to drink my Ties on the beach in the
Caribbean which I wouldn't recommend by
the way as a as a retirement plan and
instead you decide that and with your
wife that you guys are willing to you
know risk living in a tent with your
kids but you're going to do this come
hell or high water and the consequence
of that is that perversely enough you're
actually more financially secure and you
have more opportunities than you would
have otherwise had by a lot
right so that's worth thinking about
right that's really we're thinking about
because you threw yourself all in which
is what you're supposed to do and not
only did that work on the fight side
because you have been able to rescue
these children and to continue this
endeavor but none of the things that you
thought you would lose you actually
ended up losing
that's correct and I and I I'm thinking
of the words you just said five minutes
ago about when you take on the
challenges you you lose that weakness
that you otherwise would have I'd rather
I'd you know I I don't want to be weak
with with a pension like you said I I
was able to be stronger and that
strength is the thing that frankly
allowed me to expand my uh possibility
of making more income and and doing more
things in fact I often Journal um Jordan
often when I have the biggest challenges
of my life that come and hit in the face
with this or that I I take note what
blessings came what good things came and
sometimes it's ninety percent of the
good things before me
sprung out of that horrific challenge
that the darts thrown at me whatever it
was and so the principle that you're
teaching really has played out uh
accurately in my life over and over
again
yeah yeah yeah well I I think that's
well it makes sense in some sense look I
mean if we want to just think about it
practically I mean you're going to
become stronger more confident more
credible and a better Communicator in
precise proportion to the burdens that
you decide voluntarily to confront and
master like obviously because how could
it be any other way and then what that's
going to mean is that when you go
communicate with people and you tell
them what you're doing they're much more
likely to jump on board because you have
the Charisma that goes along with having
the stories to tell and those encounters
to to relate and the success you've
generated and and so then people are
going to offer to help you're not even
going to have to ask them and so let me
let me ask you about that you talked
about Glenn Beck who else has been
instrumental in helping your operation
grow and providing you with support you
mentioned Tony Robbins as well and I've
got to know Tony a bit over the last
last year or so I mean he's an
absolutely remarkable person and I think
he might be the most charismatic person
I've ever met which is really saying
something because I've met some very
charismatic people and he's quite the
monster in the world and he's done an
awful lot of good and and he's obviously
supporting he's supporting you as well
and is on board with this project and so
how did that come about
well Tony Robbins is in fact uh the the
single largest donor to to our operation
I'm super super close with him his his
wife as well Sage Beautiful People
beautiful souls uh it came about in the
most amazing way uh during one of his
big Mastermind conferences and a a
Convention Center of some sort there was
a woman who raised her hand when Tony
asks about bucket list uh projects if
you had an excess of whatever what would
you do with it she raised her hand and
said I'd support a group called
operation Underground Railroad Tony says
what is that three minutes later he says
I'll donate I'll match whatever someone
gives me right now to help rescue
children and and and that's where the
relationship was born he called me a few
days later and said is this real I said
I felt it was I said why don't you come
down to Haiti with me we're about to do
an operation and you can see how very
real it is and he did and he saw and
that converted him to our cause so
what's on your plate next what what
where is this going as far as you're
concerned and what sort of impact what
sort of impact have you had
in sheer numbers
um why do you think you're not going to
get taken out because it seems to me
that you're in a situation where that's
you know of reasonable high probability
given who you're dealing with and what
do you hope to accomplish over the next
what do you hope to accomplish over the
next while and and what can people do to
help
well so I've changed quite a bit of how
I look at the playing field of human
trafficking I can no longer do
operations I've been in the media too
much especially with this film I've
turned a lot of my attention to uh the
fact that in what I call spiritual
warfare children are targeted like never
before I was uh I was on the Capitol
Hill last week and this congressman is
telling me how do we wake people up to
the fact that all these unaccompanied
minors are being shoved into America and
we don't know where they are and and I
said well your problem is you're not
connecting all the dots all the ways in
which children are being hurt not only
these 85 000 missing children that are
now on the belly of of the largest
potentially child sex Market in the
world
um but at the same time that's happening
you have groups trying to get rid of the
name pedophile and call them minor
attracted persons at the same time
you're you're sexualizing children
giving them what I used to be able to
arrest you for giving children now
teachers in California and other states
are giving this in the name of of
liberal liberating children's sexually
or sex education and now a 13 year old
can consent to gender mutilation and
inject them have themselves injected
with all sorts of chemicals that might
ruin their reproductive system well what
are you doing consent to do that equals
consent eventually to to sex with a 50
year old pedophile and so if you you got
to connect all these things and so I I
for the first time in my life Jordan I'm
looking at the United States of America
and I'm saying I'm saying look I used to
think I might be out of a job because we
eradicated human trafficking I am now
thinking I might be out of a job because
the very laws that protect children and
allow us to go after their captors are
being and will be
decaying and eroded with this crazy
culture that is taking children in the
name of liberating them and in fact is
enslaving them so you know I I
interviewed this girl Chloe Cole who had
a double mastectomy when she was 15 and
who had puberty blockers and went
through the whole bloody
gamut of incompetent lying therapists
and sadistic butchering surgeons and
they transformed her sexually and then
she talked to me about her dating
experiences in high school now you can
just imagine this you know it's
complicated enough for a young man or a
young woman in high school to navigate
the sexual Shoals let's say and
establish a reasonable relationship or
even a reasonable sequence of
relationships if everything is roughly
normal or something approximating ideal
but Chloe put herself way out on the
fringes having done what she did and
that made that took her out of the
dating pool in high school for her
compatriots and so she turned to online
dating and you can imagine the sort of
people who attempted to pick her up and
she didn't refer to that an awful lot in
our interview but she referred to it
enough so that I got a real flavor of
the sort of people who uh were more than
perversely willing to strike up a
relationship with her often much older
as you pointed out and so you know that
that freedom that she was hypothetically
offered that only required the sacrifice
of her breasts let's say uh the wounds
of which by the way have never
completely healed so that's perfectly
goddamn delightful and you know she
talked about her dissent into that
perverse underworld of of deviant sexual
attraction and so uh yeah there's not a
lot of freedom on that front Jim
um what are you up to next like you
finished this movie it's going to open
up on July 4th
um what what's what's next for you on
the project front and and also on the
personal front in terms of of your
commitment to continuing the work that
you're starting with this movie
well it goes to the next chapter
um
which is on Haiti and that's the next
part of Tim
um when they went down and did this
Haiti Mission and this is a much better
script than the first one written by the
same director uh and Rod Barr Alejandro
monteverdi wrote this
so I plan to do that film
and um
and then of course I'm doing the
resurrection of the Christ with Mel
Gibson so I think that's going to be
I think for sure it's one film but it
might be two films I think
and when when so and what do you see
what do you foresee happening on the uh
on the theatrical release front I mean I
have the have the typical companies that
are involved in theatrical release in
movies being on board with the release
of sound of Freedom or have have you run
into like enthusiastic reception or
resistance what's happened on that front
well we had a lot of resistance it took
us four years to get where we're at
right now
um you know like The Passion of the
Christ nobody saw that as a of a
financially feasible film same thing
with this who's going to want to watch a
film about traffic children that's why
it wasn't about that it was it it points
in that direction but it's really in the
face of evil can good still Triumph and
that's what this film is so it's quite
inspirational
you know well it is a classic in many
ways it is a classic action adventure
film I mean it's based on a true story
but it's got a very solid narrative
driving line I mean it's not
fundamentally making its Appeal on the
moral side I mean there is an appeal on
the moral side don't get me wrong but
that's not good enough for a movie like
a movie has to carry its own weight as
an artistic Endeavor and it has to be
well plotted and well well acted and or
just degenerates into kind of moralistic
propaganda I don't think this movie does
that at all I also didn't think that the
chosen did that angel Studios other
major production it never degenerated
into sentimental moralizing thank God
and give that but something like that'll
just flop at the box office anyways and
I certainly couldn't see any reason
after having watched this movie not to
think that this could be a commercial
success
I mean it's a very exciting movie we're
selling out right now where our biggest
War right now is to get more theaters
the big studios control those and the
Distributors have to decide whether or
not and this happened on The Passion of
the Christ whether to go and go where
the people are
um and so the people are calling in
right now to you know ask for these
theaters they're not just going to
angel.com I've known many people that
have gone in and literally bought out
all theaters uh to do this and so we're
hoping that this continues because we
won't be able to serve the public we
just don't have enough theaters right
now well that's that's a good problem to
have I would say and that should get
also get you the kind of publicity that
should also further distribution of the
film and of course there's alternative
routes now too I mean Matt Walsh had
tremendous success Distributing what is
a woman on Twitter I think they got 170
million views and you know I don't know
how successful that was commercially and
of course that's a problem because
Financial issues matter but there's
definitely multiple venues now where a
film like this can be can be distributed
and of course Angel Studios had a hell
of a success Distributing what they
produced on the on the chosen front
using rather unorthodox channels online
and we're fortunate enough uh Jordan to
get Elon Musk he he actually tweeted out
a couple weeks ago with the trailer and
opened up Twitter as a free home for
distribution
um uh and that and they're gonna you're
gonna we're gonna see a Twitter release
uh I think mid-july so that that will be
fun to see what happens there oh so
that's already in play all right well
all right well look gentlemen we're
running out of time on the YouTube front
um as everybody watching and listening
or at least to some people watching and
listening no I do add another half an
hour of interview on The Daily wire plus
side and so I think we'll turn our
attention to that I'm gonna find out
from from Tim and Jim what
developmental route they took to the
destination that they arrived at
um I haven't done that with two people
before but I think that will be quite
entertaining and so
um I'm interested in how people's
Destinies make themselves manifest
across time or you might say how they're
calling uh makes itself uh makes its
appearance in their life because things
do call to people you know everybody has
problems that beset them that are their
problems and everybody has opportunities
that back into them that are their
opportunities and that's kind of a
mysterious
what would you say Bargain and interplay
between the psyche and the world and uh
I'm endlessly curious about how that
happens and so we're going to follow
down that road as we continue this
conversation on the daily word plus side
um by the way for those of you who are
watching and listening if you're
thinking about uh throwing some support
the daily wire plus way is probably a
good time to think about doing that
because uh they and I for that matter
have been under a fair bit of pressure
from YouTube in the last month I've had
three of my
interviews taken down and I suspect
there's a couple on the in the pipelines
that are also going to raise the hackles
of the wrong people whoever the hell
they are lurking behind the scenes and
so uh yeah yeah well you never know
right you can't tell what rules you
broke and you can't tell who's enforcing
the censorship rules
um which is real really not good on any
front so anyways we're going to turn our
attention over there
um thank you to Jim Caviezel and Tim
Bellard for talking today uh I really
enjoyed your film I'm I'm looking
forward to watching how the public will
receive it and and what the consequences
will be and wish you both luck in your
future endeavors and uh and yeah and Tim
Mouse I will hook up hook you up your
wife up with my wife and it'd be real
interesting to have them talk about you
know how she saw what you were doing and
and why she threw her weight behind it
because there's quite a story there as
well as far as I can tell I'm very much
looking forward to watching that
interview
all right gentlemen it was good to talk
to both of you and uh thank you everyone
watching and listening thanks for your
time and attention pay some attention to
this movie if you're inclined you bet
guys you bet good to meet you both
[Music]